fighting for his life tonight at umc
after a shooting that happened
on the las vegas strip late last night
well i'm kirsten joyce this happened
about 11 o'clock between the linc and
flamingo hotels police have made an
arrest
19 year old christian miller was taken
into custody in california
during a traffic stop joe moeller spoke
to family members of the victim he is
live near where the shooting occurred
joe the mother of the man who was shot
says his name is justin and he underwent
seven
surgeries today and she says she
believes he is now paralyzed
this all happened between those two
hotels the link in the flamingo right
here on the sidewalk off the strip
she tells us her 28-year-old son was in
town from seattle to help her move
he was wearing a seattle seahawks
necklace when according to her a group
of men were calling her son names when
shots rang out
justin's mom says the bullet missed his
heart and hit his kidneys causing
paralysis
christian miller was stopped for
speeding in california and was taken
into custody
the shooting comes after a string of
fights on the strip
we spoke to retired henderson police
chief and security consultant tommy
burns who says
more needs to be done i think you're
going to see metro
stepping up when they see these roving
bands of uh
of uh thugs out there i mean most some
are
verbally accosting women challenging men
to fights
uh things of that nature and it's just a
rip-roaring party really
on the strip up and down the strip and
you know people don't feel
safe
recently sheriff joe lombardo recognized
the uptick in crime on the strip he
attributed the problem to
lower room rates and less options for
activities on the stretch now back out
here live we did speak to a number of
people who were
visiting las vegas here on this strip
and they say they're not too worried
about the crime happening on here
on the strip but they are aware that it
is happening many say
they just simply head back to their
hotel room before it gets dark
reporting live here on the strip joe
bowler 8 news now